if you want to hear about how Ritchie's
teenage years are documented in another
Stephen King novel then stick around to
the end of this video I went online
clicked on this video basically dragged
me out here to the studio and now I'm
gonna have to analyze the skin character
so welcome to horror history my name is
Zack Morris you may remember me from
Saved by the death bell and in today's
lesson I'll be breaking down the story
of Richie Tozier everyone else seemed
more interested in breaking down the
glasses of Richie Tozier he's constantly
bullied for his spectacles and his loud
mouth but despite his poor eyesight
I think it's Richie's eyes littered with
the key to understanding him with that
in mind let's take it back to Ritchie's
early days as a young rock and roll
[Music]
Richie Tozier was born in the year 1945
as far as we know Richie was the only
son of a dentist named Wentworth and his
wife Maggie Maggie had hoped to have a
girl and isn't always a fan of Richie's
boisterous personality
Richie always had poor eyesight and
seemed to suffer from a metaphor
or a fear related to one's eyes one time
when he was very young he dreamt that he
had poked his eye full of blood and when
he woke up he was actually relieved that
he'd only wet the bed Richie had a good
relationship with his father when Earth
never went easy on Richie but he
understood his son and would sometimes
even do voices with him Wentworth took
Richie out to see the Paul Bunyan statue
when it was first unveiled in dairies
city centre as a kid Richie would have
most often hang out with his friends
Stan URIs and the two would sometimes go
to the Barrens and do stuff with buildin
bro and Eddie Casper and there aren't
really any Richie and Stan scenes in the
book but we're given the impression that
they're close in both movies they show
up as a pair in the 1990 version and
Richie is the only one to attend Stan's
Bar Mitzvah in the 2017 adaptation
Richie was best known for his voice
impressions which included kinky
briefcase sexual accountant Jim from
Huckleberry Finn the German commandant
toodles the English Butler now good
Pikmin tell you how my good foes the
movie newsreel narrator
grannie grunt Pancho vanilla voice
Felicio
Chinese [ __ ] and many and many more
celebrity voice impressions that
probably would have had the SJW is up in
a fin rage if the internet had been
around
back then but it wasn't so instead
Ritchie's impressions which most agreed
were rather pedestrian your voices all
sound the same which he seemed to piss
off the bullies of Derry more than
anyone they were constantly chasing him
beating him up breaking his glasses and
disliking his videos without even
watching them okay I made that last one
up but one day at school the leader of
the bullies Henry Bowers slipped on a
puddle and yeah let me just play the
clip how was this kid considered a loser
if he grew up when I did he would have
be considered a legend so after school
that day the bullies were looking for
him and they chased him all the way
through town to freeze his department
store where he hid in the toy department
then snuck out of the emergency exits
the scene is not in any movie so far but
Ritchie's friezes t-shirt in the 2017
film suggests that maybe he hid there in
the book because he knew the ins and
outs of the place now Stan might be
Jewish but Ritchie is probably the most
relatable character for me because of
his love for horror movies rock and roll
and his overwhelmingly charming person
how okay fine take that out but Ritchie
sees a poster for a rock show that he
wants to go to but knows that his mom
wouldn't let him so he sits on a bench
in the Sun and the Paul Bunyan statue
moves and stares him straight in the
face threatening to eat him the ground
would shake with Paul's enormous steps
and Paul destroyed the bench that
Ritchie had been sitting on moments
before with his giant axe when he looked
back the scene was normal this was
obviously his first encounter with it's
but Ritchie is somehow able to convince
himself that it was just a dream he
probably does have bad dreams with all
the scary movies is watching from such a
young age and his obsession with the
media can be both a strength and a point
of weakness for him this is why I think
Ritchie's eyes and glasses are so
significant because it's generally the
things he sees in movies or on TV that
scare him but it's also the things he
sees on those same programs that help
him fight back against it whether it be
his voice impressions or by using
tactics that only work in the movies in
this case though nothing really comes of
it and the experience sticks in the back
of his mom
on the first day of summer Ricci has to
stay back and help his dad clean out
their attic but the next day Richie and
Stan show up to help bill Eddie and Ben
build a dam in the stream in the Barrens
Ritchie enjoys hanging out with them
there because his antics get him in
real-world trouble but not in the
Barrens that afternoon each of them
reveals their personal encounters with
Pennywise but Richie still under the
belief that his was a dream has nothing
to share they're interrupted by mr. Nell
the Irish Derry police officer who's
angry at them for backing up the
drainage system with her Dan Ritchie
demonstrates his inability to control
his ever running mouth how's things back
in the old country mister now it bulged
ah you're a sight for sore eyes sure and
begorrah you're a lovely man credit to
the eyelids sod only bill telling
Ritchie to shut up makes him stop mr.
nel ends up making them clear it up and
agrees not to rat them out if they do
that evening bill and Ritchie are
walking home together in Richie ask to
see the picture of Georgi that winked at
bill after talking about it with Ritchie
bill starts to feel like he's in a
better place this is the first of many
examples of Ritchie offering support to
bill after being the seer of the group
this is the next most important aspect
of Ritchie's character in that he's
always there for his friends especially
bill we continue to see more of that
throughout the store it isn't until they
actually arrive in Georgie's room that
Ritchie starts to freak himself out a
little bit he can see the dried blood on
the pages of the album and feel the cold
touch of its pages George a school
picture is missing but there's a photo
from the olden days of Derry with two
sailors they were Ritchie and Bill the
photo comes to life like a movie and
they see Pennywise pop over the edge of
the canal like a jack-in-the-box
only it has Georgie's face Ritchie saves
bill by pulling him out of the photo
after he tries to reach his hand inside
and they flee from Georgie's room this
is the first time that Ritchie realizes
that what they all saw were not just
stories or movies the thing that had
been haunting Gary was a monster
[Music]
Richie Tozier would have been subscribed
to this channel with death Bell
notifications on because Richie was a
fan of horror movies and one Saturday
not too long after the day that took
down the dam I was a teenage werewolf
was playing at the Aladdin theater in
town he bargains with his dad to earn
two dollars and fifty cents for mowing
the lawn though Richie claims that this
is blackmail because his father knows he
wants to go to the show keep in mind
this was 1958 it didn't cost $17.50 to
get into a movie or $15 a month for
movie fast you and me Ben Hanscom also
has no money having spent it on junk
food so Richie spots him then they run
into Beverly Marsh Richie admired Bev's
looks but mostly liked her sense of
humor Bev doesn't have any money and
Richie pays for her tickets as well
since the tickets were only 25 cents
which they jokingly referred to as a
date they sat on the balcony to avoid
Henry Bowers and his gang but they were
spotted on the way out and surrounded in
the alley next to the movie theater as
they tried to sneak away then led the
escape effort by throwing a garbage can
to knock over Henry Bowers and Richie
ended up using the lid as a shield
blocking a punch from the Bell chuggins
and helping them get free and escape the
next time bill and Richie get together
they decide to go to the house on
niebolt Street to investigate Eddy's
story about the encounter with it
Ritchie rides on the back of Bill's bike
they crawl in through a broken window
and discover a coal pits in the basement
the cellar door flies open and a
werewolf wearing loafers faded jeans and
a dairy high school jacket enters the
room
remember it's the things that Ritchie
sees in the media that scare him so it
takes the form of the teenage werewolf
from the movie he had seen I also think
that because Ritchie is basically the
eyes of the group whenever they're
together it usually takes the form of
Richie's fear bill brought along his
father's done but that doesn't hurt the
werewolf nearly as much as Ritchie who
uses his Irish cop voice to scream at it
with a sense of authority he also throws
sneezing powder at the creature sending
it into a fit something that would
probably only work in the movies but it
works because Ritchie believes in it
it's likely that it's detected Ritchie
is the seer of the group and tried to go
for his eyes the two escaped on bills
bike and they look back to see the clown
Pennywise is now coming after them in a
dairy high-school jacket as the calendar
rolled over into July Ritchie often
found himself in the company of Bill
Eddy then Beverly and Stan
Henry and his gang would refer to them
as the losers Club on July 3rd they got
together to shoot off fireworks when a
boy named Mike Hamlin a pro
mic was being chased by Henry Bowers the
losers Club help defend Mike by fighting
back against the Bowers gang by throwing
rocks Ritchie joins in in pelting Moose
Sadler the tank of the opposition and
the now seven losers are able to drive
Henry and his thugs away that's when
they welcomed Mike into the group and
with the seven of them the wheel is
complete they decided to build a
clubhouse in the Barrens for protection
against Bowers Ritchie brought along his
battery-powered radio so that they could
listen to rock and roll while they
worked rock and roll is one of the few
things that the losers Club and the
Bowers gang seem to agree on where is
the older generation the parents of
Derry are against it
Ritchie is kind of the authority when it
comes to rock music among the seven of
them there seems to be a bit of a
parallel between the music and the
ability to see the manifestations of it
for example Bill's parents are unable to
see the blood in Georgie's room and
Beverly's parents can't see the blood in
her bathroom in general the adults in
town all turn a blind eye to violence
but the kids the rock and rollers can
see it the losers Club in particular
grow up and hold on to their love of
rock and roll and they become some of
the few adults who are able to see EDS
one day Mike brings his father's dairy
photo album and Pennywise animates in
one of the pictures and threatens to
kill the losers the first forum its
changes into is Ritchie's werewolf
because it always seems to start with
the form that scares Ritchie the eyes of
the group
later that month Ben Hanscom has an idea
about how they should proceed in
fighting back against it he tells what
he knows about the Indian smoke ceremony
basically Indian tribes would come
together when they had to make a big
decision and they'd sit around the fire
in a smoke hole until one of them had a
vision telling them what to do the
losers decided to try it inside their
new clubhouse but the smoke is too much
for Stan Ben and Eddie Ritchie sees
their five by five foot Clubhouse expand
Beverly and eventually bill end up
bailing out as well leaving just Richie
and Mike the room seems to have expanded
to the size of a ballroom and it was
getting so smoky that they could barely
see each other
then Ritchie felt himself float up they
weren't inside anymore they were
standing in the middle of the Barrens
Ritchie the seer and Mike the historian
were seeing the arrival of it thousands
or even millions of years ago like a
movie only they were a part of it
a burning object falls through the
clouds and Ritchie's first thought was
that it's a spaceship he's able to
determine this without
even knowing that it is a cosmic
creature animals flee the area of the
impact and Ritchie and my shrah pulled
out of the snow : by the others it took
Ritchie a while to come to and the
others admitted that they didn't think
he was going to survive he threw up
twice but he had to survive to tell the
story I mean I guess Mike could have
also told them but it sounds a lot more
believable of what the same story coming
from two people for the first time in
his life it was Ritchie who could see
things and the others that could not and
this moment would be ingrained in his
mind for years and years to come almost
three decades in fact until he needed it
most
[Music]
here's a riddle for you what's the best
way to come out of an ad break with an
arm break Eddy gets his broken by Henry
I apologize that was I'll try not to do
that again Ritchie is there when the
losers sneak back to the hospital to
sign Eddy's cast while his mother isn't
there Eddie's mother is definitely not a
fan of Ritchie's foul mouth and habit of
smoking cigarettes while they were
waiting for mrs. Cass back to [ __ ] off
they did a little target practice with a
slingshot at the Barons trying to
determine who should be the one to shoot
Pennywise Ritchie only nicked one out of
the ten cans but he held on to one of
the cans that Beverly had punctured as a
proof of concept over the course of the
rest of that July Ritchie was there to
support his friends every step of the
way first when bill broke down in the
rain and screams out about how he's
going to kill Pennywise then it's
Ritchie and Bill who get the idea to
make silver bullets to fire at it and
then finally on July 25th they arrived
at the 29 niebolt house to try to take
the clown down in the movie Ritchie
freaks out when he finds a missing
poster of himself but in the book he's
just grossed out when he opens a
cupboard to find a litter of rats they
get to the last door which seems to have
been a bathroom with white shards lying
everywhere from the destroyed toilet as
if Badlands jugs are just taking a
message as always when Ritchie's around
the form that it takes is the teenage
werewolf with the high school letterman
jacket
Ritchie is the first to realize what
form it's taking in screams out to warn
the others and although the losers take
a couple of tough shots they're able to
drive it back
into the sewers the two weeks that
follow are pretty uneventful and consist
of a lot of games of Parcheesi the day
of the big confrontation with it starts
with Richie and Eddie getting popsicles
in town when Bev and Ben come to warn
everyone that Henry Bowers had lost it
and was trying to kill her under the
orders of it bill decides that now was
the time to retaliate and they climb
into the sewers at the pumping station
in the Barrens Richie is the last one to
go in and sees Henry run up and slip on
a puddle so he yells hey banana heels
before climbing down when Henry tries to
go in after them
Ritchie bit him in the ankle before
running up with his friends in the
drainpipe thus fully earning his
nickname of trashmouth Tozier
ready navigated as they searched for its
lair in the sewer sometimes having to
scoot or crawl to fit through the pipes
at some point it gradually started to
get lighter and Richie noticed what
would be the first form of it's the
losers would face down in the sewers a
giant eye with six tentacles resembling
the crawling hi a horror movie that
Ritchie was afraid of this form combined
his sensitivity to his eyes and meta
phobia that I mentioned earlier and the
tendency for it to use the forms of
horror movies that Ritchie had seen in
order to scare the entire group they are
only able to escape when Eddie the only
one who wasn't restrained attacks the AI
by believing his aspirator was filled
with battery acid and spraying after
moving on from the crawling eye and
entering the lair Ritchie saw the rotted
bodies of some kids who had been
abducted by it's during that summer and
the one that really hit home was Edward
Corcoran a boy who is the same age as
Ritchie the true form of its is the dead
lights but the losers clubs human minds
aren't able to process something like
that so they see it as a giant spider
Bill is successful in his mind battle
against it in the macro verbs a fight
where Ritchie plays a major turning
point in the movie in the book version
it's mostly just bill vs. it in the
other dimension but as Ritchie started
to sense that they were coming back from
the Mak reverse a ripple went through
his body sending his glasses crashing to
the floor and shattering the losers
escape from the sewers and each one of
them partakes in the promise a blood
oath that if it should ever come back
they would come back to try to kill it
again during this promise bill notices
that Ritchie's face looks different
without his glass
this is symbolic of the fact that after
defeating it
each loser stops being a loser and
starts transitioning into the successful
adults that they would become with it
thrown back into a deep sleep Ritchie
would no longer need to be the group's
ear and after overcoming such a huge
obstacle by defeating it Ritchie would
no longer be bothered by trivial things
such as being bullied for his glasses or
his emetophobia also most of the bullies
were dead at this point so that probably
helps Ritchie stayed close to his six
friends but that would be the last time
the whole group got together in the same
place at the same time in the Stephen
King novel 11/22/63 Ritchie makes a
small and questionably Canon appearance
an English teacher named Jake Epping
travels back in time to prevent the
assassination of an American president
and he ends up stopping in Derry during
the fall of 1958 approximately two
months after the losers Club defeats it
whenever you're dealing with time travel
you run the risk of creating in multiple
timelines believe me I'm a Legend of
Zelda fan I know
so there may now be a timeline where
Jake Epping interferes and one where he
doesn't
however the dairy that Jacob is it seems
to be at least very similar to the one
in the novel it for example there's a
mention of Patrick Hawke stutters body
being discovered in the Barrens which
lines up with the events of it jake
discovers Beverley and Richie dancing
near the fence on the border of the
Barrens and is taken back by their
joyfulness perhaps they're more relaxed
than the rest of the town now because
they are two of the seven people that
realized that the threat has now passed
and no more murders are going to take
place
Bev and Richie are able to connect with
Jake because as an outsider he seems to
realize the disconnected nature of most
of the adults in town
going back to my rock and roll analogy
from earlier it would be reasonable to
say that Jake is on the same page as
them because he's probably grown up on
rock and roll himself having been born
in the late 70s also during this meeting
Beverley expresses her belief that it is
merely sleeping so it's possible that
the losers quickly came to this
conclusion after the events of 1958 they
were not wrong Richie and the losers
club would eventually have to come back
and fulfill their promise when it's rose
again in the 80s but before that
happened Richie had some growing up to
do
in the spring of 1960 Ritchie's family
relocated to the Midwest and the
memories started to fade throughout his
teenage years in the year 1965 around
the age of 18 Ritchie switches from
eyeglasses to contact lenses thus
officially completing the transition
into adulthood that began with the fall
of EDS but his glasses would stay with
him in a way throughout his adulthood
shortly after he started college and
became a DJ at his school radio station
and he was pretty good at it
Ritchie already saw his own potential to
be great he was a hit on his campus and
eventually he moved to Hollywood to
pursue his dream further that same year
that he moved to California he fell in
love with a woman named Sandy she
neither of them wanted sandy to get
pregnant so Ritchie got a vasectomy
Ritchie continued to date sandy for
another two and a half years until a job
offer sent her to Washington and Ritchie
was brought on as a DJ for a Los Angeles
FM radio station called que la dee one
year after their breakup Ritchie woke up
with the sudden urge to get his
vasectomy reversed and went to a doctor
to find out if he could only to discover
that he had undergone an extremely rare
spontaneous regeneration in other words
Ritchie's sperm had been healthy for
some time including the time that he was
with sandy each member of the losers
Club has unexplained infertility
although Richie may actually be the
exception to this because he's a smoker
and he didn't quit until 1981 four years
after that in 1985 Richie is at work
when he receives a call from Mike Hanlon
letting him know that it had come back
he calls his travel agent to arrange a
flight and she asked him to do his kinky
briefcase sexual accountant voice as she
makes arrangements for him to stay at
the dairy townhouse hotel his manager
Steve choose him out for skipping out
when he's actually scheduled for a
broadcast tomorrow where he's supposed
to interview Clarence Clement without
realizing it Ritchie packs a bunch of
kids clothes into his suitcase a sign of
the rock-and-roll loving comedian kids
still being alive inside of him after
Mike's call Ritchie's childhood memories
start to trickle back and in the plane
ride on the way to Derry Richie feels
the same burning sensation in his eyes
that he felt during the smoke hole
ceremony when he was 11 years old
as the group reconvenes they began to
reassume their old roles and Richie
feels the eyes that discovered its
origin and basically dictated the forms
of its returning to their old roles as
well after his plane lands he drives the
rest of the
in a rental car but he pulls over when
he sees the sign for Penobscot County
Derry Maine I'm guessing that's not the
same sign that I pointed out of my
things you missed episode on the 2019
Pet Sematary because that one didn't
mention Penobscot County but don't worry
all you pet sematary fans out there
because when Richie pulls over an orang
Kok emic the fertilizer truck roars past
him on the highway this is the same type
of truck that runs back and forth on the
road where the Creed family lives in Pet
Cemetery but this isn't an episode of
things you missed this is horror history
so let's continue on with the history of
Richie Tozier
Richie joins Mike bill Eddy Ben and
Beverly for a reunion lunch at jade of
the Orient where Mike fills them in on
everything that's gone down in Derry
since its reawakening after the meal
they received their fortune cookies and
each one contains a horrific surprise
from Pennywise pertaining to the person
who opened it Richie's contains an eye
see all that stuff I've been saying this
entire video wasn't [ __ ] everyone
decides to go to a place they remember
best from Derry Richie gets into a cab
and the driver is the same man who had
taken Bill around earlier a particularly
foul-mouthed guy who constantly adds the
disclaimer
pardon my french if you're a religious
man I wish I got to see the scene
actually play that trashmouth versus
trashmouth it would have been real
interesting Richie goes back to the city
centre the place where he was nearly
killed by the Paul Bunyan statue as a
child he remembered the incident that
had happened back then then he sees a
poster in a similar style to one of the
posters for rock shows that his mother
never would have let him go to but the
concert being advertised was something
called Richie Tozier zall dead rahkshi I
think when Richie discovers his own
missing poster in the movie this is what
the director was trying to replicate
when he looked back to the Paul Bunyan
statue Paul was no longer there in his
place as a giant plastic version of
Pennywise the dancing clown and the lips
bleeding with red paint parted to reveal
huge razor pointed teeth this time
however Richie ran for it
you could hear Pennywise his voice
booming after him he made it to the
sidewalk to see that the statue had been
replaced yet again this time with one of
his favorite rock idols Buddy Holly he
feels an immense pain in one of his
contacts and blinks it out of his eye
all returns to normal but Richie can
still hear the laughter of Pennywise
echoing in his head that night they all
reconvened at the library for drinks and
reminiscence when Richie has an epiphany
and he remembers seeing the arrival of
its
smoke all for the first time since he
was a kid when this happens he reaches
to push his glasses up on his nose
temporarily forgetting that he'd been
wearing contacts for the last 20 years
and once again he feels the smoke in his
eyes before they leave scars on their
hands that were cut for the blood oath
all of those years ago reopened and
everyone joins hands causing the inside
of the library to go into a whirlwind of
power Ritchie goes back to the hotel and
starts to fall asleep when he receives a
phone call from Beverly asking him to
come to Eddie's room without asking
questions he shows up to a room with a
maimed Eddie Casper AK and a dead Henry
Bowers they find out that Mike was
attacked before he left the library so
Ritchie calls the hospital using his
news reporter voice to gather
information that the police chief
wouldn't give out to them the group
decides that enough was enough
it was responsible for the suicide of
their friend Stan and possibly the death
of Mike Eddie had also been injured the
only thing left for them to do was kill
that Incline Ritchie took the wheel and
Beverly Eddie bill and Benton piled into
the limousine that Eddie had driven a
diary their destination was the Barons
the place where they had climbed down
into the sewers to try to kill it 27
years ago
Pennywise uses the car radio to taunt
them and threaten them first doing an ad
read for the Richie Tozier all dead rock
show that reminds me it's time for me to
play an ad as well but don't go away
because Richie Tozier plays a hand in
the final showdown with it literally
Ritchie parks the limo next to the
bridge and they go to the pumping
station where they had entered the
sewers once before the machinery had
been turned off and they were able to
descend into the sewers trudge and crawl
their way through dirty water and sewage
eventually finding the inner layer of it
again their minds are unable to process
the deadlines but this time they're able
to tell that there's some other shape
behind the spider which is described as
being like someone moving behind a movie
screen which I find interesting because
of the tendency of it to take the form
of the monsters that Ritchie is seen in
movies the spider comes for Bill and the
ritual begins once again bill and it's
engage in an out-of-body showdown in the
matter
reverse this time it doesn't go as well
for Bill the celestial being known as
the turtle is no longer there to help
him Richie notices this back in the
chamber because he sees bill space can't
or as if his spirit is in pain or
struggling all along Ritchie has been
the support for Bill the photo album
twenty-nine nibbles the stormy afternoon
in the Barrens being a few examples
Ritchie runs up to the spider stinger
and uses his Irish cop voice to distract
it he gets whacked into the darkness by
hits and joins bill in the macro verse
where he does what bill was unable to do
this time around he bites into its
metaphysical tongue and hangs on tight
he flies past the shell of the turtle
possibly its corpse he approaches
another barrier but he can't grasp the
shape but he thinks it could be a wall
of steaks no no not those steaks these
steaks may be a reference to its
appearing abandoned the form of Dracula
one time Ritchie finds Bill and takes
his hand then turns the tables on it and
threatens to kill it right then and
there if it doesn't bring them back to
the physical world
Ritchie uses his mind to hang on tight
to it nearly losing his grip before
arriving back in the actual spiders
chamber when they come back they find
Eddie seriously injured as he had tried
to attack it with his aspirator as he
did to the crawling eye in 1958 but he
got his arm dismembered and was bleeding
out on the floor of the chamber heads
heads oh my god bill been someone he's
lost his arm has looked up at Beverly
and saw she was crying the tears
coursing down her dirty cheek Ritchie
what Ritchie was down in his hands and
knees staring at him desperately
don't call me EDS he said and smiled
those would be Eddie's final words
Beverly took him in her arms and urged
Ritchie who wanted to stay in comfort
Eddie in his final moments to go on
after the spider so that it doesn't come
back after another 27 years that thing
comes back when I'm 70 let's finish
bill and Ritchie chased it to the
deepest part of the chamber further than
they'd ever been before it begs them to
let it go offering them power success
and long lives beyond their wildest
dreams
they both simultaneously plunged into
it's the monster lashed out at them
injuring Ritchie who struggled not to
drown in its guts bill ended it when he
crushed the heart of it in his hands
where it exploded bill took Ritchie and
his arms and tried to find Beverley and
Ben in the dark since the dead lights
that had been illuminating the place
died along with the spider when they
reconvene Ritchie comes back to the
tunnel that they're in starts shaking a
side effect of the violent storm taking
place above them they have to leave Eddy
behind in order to try to save Bill's
wife Audra and Ritchie carries her for a
bit as they make their way back to the
surface perhaps his final gesture of
support towards his friend bill Ritchie
flew back to California a few days later
and after the defeat of its each member
of the losers Club gradually started to
lose their memories of everything that
happened in derry
later in the week Mike Hanlon gave
Ritchie a call in Beverly Hills at first
it went to the answering machine and
when Ritchie picked it up he said that
he let Mike talk to the answering
machine for as long as he did because
for a slight moment he had no idea who
Mike was just like when Mike first
reached out to him to tell his old
friends that it had come back Richie
Tozier was a joker and a troublemaker
but he played an important part in the
group using his eyes and his creative
voice impressions to help him stand a
chance against it and he was always
there for his pals when they needed it
kind of like how I'm gonna be here for
you the viewers with more episodes of
horror history just click the playlist
on the left to see me analyze more
characters like Bill den brow Stan URIs
and others and remember to subscribe to
seize these worlds for new Horrors every
week bring the death Bell for
notifications so even if you do lose
your memories I'll still be able to see
you in the next one assuming we both
survive